by the way you can go on our app
and watch the harry styles performances
i know he's got a lot of fans and
they're worth watching
it if you can take it
because look at you
look at you
is that who you want that's the latest
you know that i didn't know what do i
know what's going on in your head if you
had your choice timothy chalamet
or harry styles no now there's a a real
hair splitter right
i think i'm going with harry wow
music wins
you you you don't fantasizing about like
the rocks i'm pumped
you like a nice skinny boy you know
where so where did let let me give you
some brackets what about like a brad
pitt you know in his heyday
you know you can keep brad pitt right
now brad pitt's doing well yeah oh okay
okay brad pitt now or harry styles
i'm taking harry though wow wow boy this
kid is on fire look at this there's
something about him he's spiritual you
know like and when he wears his greatest
attitude about
you know supporting
other people's right to be whoever they
are and his
i mean all of it just works
even the necklaces
necklace everything i went home
and i zoomed in
and you looked okay yeah all right what
about okay it's knowing you and knowing
what you know sean connery in his prime
who i know you loved is james bond yeah
or um stop it
big dick energy okay all right now this
see this is what happens i can't talk to
you about this stuff you start blurting
out i get
gideon yelling
yelling things out sean connery in his
prime or
harry styles no i mean harry potter okay
all
all day long bradley bradley cooper who
we've had on the show
bradley cooper or harry's okay nice
penis for sure bradley cooper nice penis
or harry styles harry styles i guess
yeah
okay okay i'll give you one last one and
i'm done paint his penis penis
george clooney
oh you can't put george on any list
because i've never thought of george
clooney that way oh okay
all right this is one you're gonna have
to think about right
harry styles or jake gyllenhaal i knew
you were gonna do that to me yeah poor
woman come on give me give it to me
see what i tell you
jake gyllenhaal
hey what you got in your pants
i gotta go with jade
you gotta go with jake oh
good for you
wow
yeah wow wow
i was just reading about jake gyllenhaal
i bet you were
you